Gary W. Goldstein, Producer/Author/Instructor:
I’m not going to share who I am as an artist,
as a creator, as a writer. I’m going to put out a
blind query letter with a log line, etc and I’ll
send it to a stranger who does not yet know me and
I’m going to hope and pray to get a good response.
Film Courage: Is Hollywood a game, Gary?
Gary: In a sense yes I suppose but I think
life in a way is a game in the best sense.
But you sort of have to understand the rules of
it. People talk about ‘breaking into Hollywood,’
which I always find fascinating because life is
not an event, it's a process right and I think
when people think about…people are very given
to stories in their craft and their dream of
what it is they want to accomplish we know at
show business. But very few people really think
about the business side of the equation and
I find a lot of creatives in particular are
not intentionally random but they end
up being random in their approach,
focusing on craft not thinking
about how they're going to navigate.
As if our industry is somehow different from
all other industries which it's not I mean
it is in a sense but it's not in the sense of
being relationship based um and I you know what
what I would encourage people is I try and train
people to be hyper focused hyper intentional
radically transparent and not think about needing
a representative so much as being themselves a
presence developing rapport creating relationships
in this business and understanding that the first
thing they have to know is who are you who are
you in the world what do you care about what
what's your creative DNA what's your signature
what what are the kinds of stories you want to be
participating in or writing or directing
or producing whatever it might be
and then thinking about if that's true
who is it that I really need to know if
hypothetically if I could have a hundred
people over time be my champions and mentors
who would they be and that's going to be
different from me to the person sitting next to me
and then making that reality come to come to be
right I think a lot of a lot of people are taught
unfortunate habits so they learn they mimic habits
of of their peers which may or may not be optimal
writers may for example send upline query letters
that are deeply impersonal and fly into strangers
in boxes asking them to either produce it or
represent them or whatever it might be a big ask
as opposed to humanizing the process over and
again time and time again I get the sense that
people people have a story that Hollywood
is not welcoming that it's um that they
have they don't understand their value and
they don't know that the welcome mat is out
which couldn't be further from the truth if
you approach people the way you would in any
other environment so what I wish for people is
that they get more comfortable being vulnerable
and telling people what's unique about them
why who are they what's what's what's some
any one really delicious unexpected uh nugget from
their life experience that makes them memorable
tell people share with people what was why was
this particular of all the possible stories in the
universe why this one what's the connective tissue
why was that so important to you that you put
all your soul equity into creating this and
a third leg of this school very important is
don't just send it out randomly
if I want to send you this project
why you why have I chosen you not
because your name was in a directory
I researched you there was some one film that you
made perhaps that was um like I got sucker punched
in the third eye it's so spot on or maybe it's
your entire body of work there's something that
called me to think you might be a right size fit
a good match for me and for this particular story
say those things pick up the phone don't rely on
social media don't rely on blind query letters
make it personal this is a personal business
reach out to someone and do not be a snob
you're not going to probably reach the name on
the door nor do you necessarily need to I've
always learned I built my entire career based on
one simple realization early on all I need to do
is befriend the assistant the assistant or of
any you know when assistants move on they go to
the next little notch up which is still entry
level it's creative executive it's a director
production it's a you know head of
development whatever their titles
all of those people beginning with the person who
answers the phone which is usually an assistant
these are your target these are
the people who have enormous value
who are so aligned with you you have so
much in common with them they are highly
vetted they are usually like they beat out 50
people or more to get that particular perch
they're ambitious they're sitting
on the inside learning the business
on a producer's desk or an agent's desk
or whatever it might be casting studio
and they are going to last in that position for 18
24 some number of months and they will matriculate
because they're really good and
they've had to work really hard and
and you know that's their sharpening stone
these people need relationships with you as
much as you need one with them and most people
don't understand that it's like the currency
of most of us is who's what relationships
do I enjoy with talent in front of the camera
behind the camera it doesn't matter do I know
other good producers writers cinematographers
actors whatever it might be casting directors
we're all in the business of relationship and so
it's a beautiful game of human failures and
everyone is instead of being narrow focused and
saying i'm just going to i'm not going to share
who I am as an artist as a creator as a writer i'm
going to put out a blind query letter with a log
line etc and i'll send it to a stranger who does
not yet know me and i'm going to hope and pray
to get a good response and the common refrain is
not a positive response I send out hundreds
I get two responses there usually passes
very typical as opposed to saying i'm going to
dare to be uncomfortable and awkward for a moment
i'm going to take a minor risk it's not
threatening my life but i'm going to take
a minor risk of being uncomfortable and i'm
going to call someone who does not know me
and i'm going to introduce myself
and i'm not going to ask a big favor
the first couple of calls i'm only going to ask
advice it's gonna that's what I learned early
on is like make everyone your mentor ask
advice keep the call to three four minutes
do it again a week later do it again
a week later make a friend and they're
as desirous of that as you are you just have
to catch them when they're not overwhelmed
um so I think I think you know it it's a funny
word is Hollywood a game and I think yeah if
you want to win at this if you really want to
have a viable sustainable career as a creative
what's interesting is the artist you all you
know everyone has more than one story one hopes
um and the story may be brilliant but
what makes it really interesting is the
point of view of the creator and why they did
it and what's their life experience we we react
to one another we are attracted to that and even
if someone falls in love with one of your scripts
they're never going to go forward
with it and lessen until they meet you
the creator so I think I think in a sense
you know it's it's really having that sort of
divine inspiration that just comes down and
gives you the permission like oh my gosh I
don't need permission I can just reach out and
talk to whoever I want no one is unreachable
that was my earliest lesson no one is unreachable
if you're humble if you're vulnerable if you're
if if you make it pleasant you're you know and
you can say to someone oh my gosh i'm terrified
i'm so nervous to be calling you even to an
assistant because it's true as long as it's true
um but the more you let yourself be known
and the more other focused you become
the more generous you are the more
you share and ask questions that are
like of human you know truly interesting
to humans it's it works magic
if you win over an assistant and I know i'm
rambling on but if you went over an assistant
you went over everybody in that office
because they have the full trust of
everyone in that office they've been hired
relied on they're a critical part of the
of that mission um if you want to win over
an aw you know a group of people
get to know their assistant
so it is a game in some sense and to get
in the game you find that one assistant
person that's there before
everyone else maybe making coffee
getting it ready answering the phones
how do you do it in a way that's genuine
well the question is the answer by being
genuine and saying you know I when I was new
i would just turn to people and say i'm new
i'm the turnip that just fall off the truck
but i'm really committed to making it in this
business but I know how much I don't know
I have a couple of questions if you could
spend three minutes answering my questions
it would mean the world to me people can't
resist the truth if it's real if it's genuine
when I would call assistance of
course you don't know who they are
it's just a person answering the phone and I
would just introduce myself and say look this
is and it's what I was talking about earlier I
am an aspiring screenwriter or fill in the blank
I am absolutely mesmerized by the work your
company consistently puts out into the world
that's why i'm reaching out and yes
I have a project that's very much
that shares a lot of kinship with the kinds of
projects stories that you tell but i'm not sending
it to you i'm not asking you to read my script
I just want to establish a relationship with you
and I get their name so that I can when i'm off
the call research them and find out all sorts
of delicious stuff about them online um and I
will have a question or two and it's usually
something I know they can answer it's it might be
you know how do you operate as a company are you
you know i'm not going to send you my script but
do you accept outside material it could be uh were
you there at the time they made this last film
that came out in march that was just so phenomenal
how did you get to be there how did how did you
get to work for this extraordinary company and
where do you want to go I mean I know you don't
want you know you're you're paying dues you're
sitting in the crosshairs of this amazing
opportunity but where do you see yourself
in a few years um you know where'd you
go to school did you go to film school
i'll ask any question that
comes up in the moment for me
but there but there'll be questions to which I
really do want the answer it'll be it'll help
inform me about this person and I always build in
and say look you know I've used up my four minutes
you've been amazingly kind to take my call I
just want you to know I really appreciate it
and I have another question i'm thinking about
a couple of things but i'd like you know what
you're busy i'm you know i'm going to let you
go but i'm going to call you a week from today
if you have three or five minutes available that
would be absolutely extraordinary but thank you
I researched the heck out of them I called them
back the next week exactly when I said I would
and if they're available great and if they're
not I call back again my idea is that people are
very welcoming if that's your expectation
that's probably going to be the reality
if you welcome that it can be a very welcoming
experience I don't mind people sending me query
letters but i'll tell you there's universe galaxy
of difference between if someone sends me a query
letter and I've never spoken I have no idea
who they are and they're sending me a storyline
with the goal of me reading it and possibly
producing it or whatever their intention is um
versus someone who's reached out
to either me or someone on my team
making themselves known as a human developing some
rapport taking the time investing a multiple of
calls over the course of a month let's say and now
they're really familiar with someone on my team
and that person and this happens all
the time whether it was as a manager
or as a producer someone would come to me
and say you know I've met so and so and
they're really nice I think they're really
smart and I've just read some of their work
because you do that after three or four
calls now the the the welcome mat is out
would you take a look at it my answer is
always yes that's that's my team member
you know and and and that's kind of the reality
now it might not be direct to me it might be to my
head of development or it might be some but that's
how you penetrate that's how you get welcomed in
a query letter after you've spoken with a human
that's addressed to the human you spoke to
is a totally different experience than
just a strange peach unexpected email
coming into my inbox or someone else you
know why why is it coming into my inbox
and I that's not to be that's
not hubris it's just pragmatism
there are so many ways to play
the long game build rapport
with the faith that the long game
is actually the faster track.
Question For The Viewers:
What do you like about this
advice? Anything you disagree with?